thank you so much for passing through a
new day a new update for Bitcoin
I have to say that I'm I appreciate all
the support that the videos are getting
I see that you guys are enjoying the
content so then I'm enjoying making it
for you and yes I'm also very happy how
with how this week is going because we
were anticipating to be a very hard week
to trade and so it is it's been a really
difficult week but still we managed to
get some very good traits okay and
yesterday's uh and today was one of them
because we were with this projection
in yesterday's video and I managed here
to get a scalp okay let me tell you
first a bit of context so uh yesterday
we do this this projection you know hit
the liquidity pool and then go to the
week obviously it's a lot of these
things is like one thousand and a half
yeah well two thousand move two thousand
dollars move from here so it's a very
big move so I might take days to develop
but that's kind of for original
projection okay but yesterday something
interesting happened after I posted the
video
so this week let's go to the 15 minutes
time frame we saw this week
okay hitting is the liquidity pool is
straight away to 550 half my entry point
of 515
okay so it'll let me go into short and
then he just went all the way down to 28
850. my position was closed also I think
at 20 no 20 950 I think it was or or
five 960 something like that so that was
a nice scalp okay
across that one manually I didn't have
any any any limit a sell order and I
posted also on Twitter when I closed it
because
when when you guys have an order an
entry point and you see price a straight
away reacting in the opposite way so
fast
you can't really truth that move that
much why because he's living a week
behind okay look at this week it's a
week of how much four hundred dollars
okay and I was in in nothing in no time
so you were expecting then price to go
back up and retrace that week okay so
that's what I mean just you could just
take profits and then re-enter
um I posted also here that I was not
re-entering at the moment because I saw
some momentum look at this Candlestick
is quite strong and then price was you
know I woke up this morning early and I
saw price was you know consolidating
under the liquidity pool So I entered a
short I think at six seven in the
morning so it was around here this is
UTC time and I was sitting at a profit
because you can see that it seems that
it's going to the right direction it
just broke below the 50 EMA in the one
hour time frame I'm only have two hours
until the candles close so if the candle
close below the 50 I mean the daily in
the one hour time frame
resistance then yes we're expecting
lower prices but guys take this with a
pinch of salt okay because you know I
appreciate your support on YouTube on
Twitter
but please don't be like crypto said
this is going to happen so it's going to
happen no
don't be like that don't put your money
just because somebody else's has done an
analysis and is projecting lower prices
you should have your own idea first and
then you can use other Traders analysis
to give you a bit of confidence okay but
never Trace based on others analysis you
know these videos
they are only to give you a bit of an
idea of what I see that might happen but
it's not a signal call it's not telling
you you know entry entering the
liquidity pool
and short all the way to the wake no
because that's not how trading works
because then I might just go like
yesterday happened I'll make this
straight into a scalp and then re-enter
again here okay or at the end I might
lose my trade if it goes into the right
direction at the 50mm in the four hour
time frame and all the way to the week
so this is what I mean guys make your
own analysis make your own trading
system or learn from others but at the
end of the day you have to create your
own analysis and be responsible of them
anyway we just had a candle close Okay
it closed below the 50 EMA in the one or
time frame and now let's see how this
new candle closes okay because if it
closes below it again with a little weak
testing it as resistance then you could
expect
lower prices but for now this just might
be some kind of fake out and now the
next candle might be like this okay and
then you can consolidate and go higher
so keep an eye on that now you need to
ask yourself what's the invalidation of
your trade
and where would you flip your position
okay so mine is clear you know break up
of this Zone you know test is a support
and then we're gonna see prices going
higher if you go down to the Daily time
frame
we're gonna see that the chart is
actually not looking bad at all look at
all these weeks testing the 50 EMA in
the daily time frame this is only
telling you that the support is solid
okay so we might be heading into the
next Zone to the upside where to well if
you go to the left in the chart the next
Zone in principle
would be this resistance over here
dies where price went last time before
there was a sell-off okay you can say
that Consolidated and then it is you
know there was another set of and price
went lower so that would be the next one
the next area of interest for selling so
it's whatever we tell you guys you know
it's not worth it to to have bias if you
are a Trader if you are an investor of
course yes you know you have to you have
to think that something bullish to put
your money on it and just hold that and
just hold the position
but if you're a Trader what would you be
a bull or a bird it doesn't make any
sense you should be able to flip your
bias at any second a good Trader knows
the invalidation of the trade
and you know crosses the trade at a loss
but a great Trader changes the trade
okay so if you are going short
and then you're short
gets invalidated
you know a great trade I would open a
lock
keep that in mind you know it's
basically like a quick
speech to say that it doesn't make any
sense to
to have any bias if you're a Trader you
know the only thing you're interested is
in volatility
and opportunities to make money
a Trader can make money if price goes up
or if price goes down an investor can't
really okay an investor if you are
holding a position
then you need price to go up then yes
you can have a bullish bias
or a better spot if you want price to go
down to buy cheaper
but Trader why well you know we're
Traders we are not who are no investors
let's check the SMP because yesterday
did a very interesting move okay
look at this
where in this song
I want to be in the four hours time
frame
look at what happened yesterday
look at this Bounce from here okay we're
talking about uh
two and a half percent move for the SMP
that's huge okay
um
I would say that's probably because they
are in reports they've all been better
than expected
you know alphabet Microsoft meta Amazon
they will be better than expected
and if you notice those companies that I
just mentioned they have a huge market
cap in their stocks so they are a big
part of the SMP price okay so that's my
logic that's why I think price has bound
so hard but now anyway I think I would
let me remove this and also the 50ma I
would say that we are still in this
sideways move okay so you know you can
trade a range because this is at the end
of the base range look let me check this
for you if I mark this Zone I will say
that this is my high
and
I would say that this is my low okay
this one over here so you can see the
price what basically did was
here it was playing between the high and
the low of the range you can see
then goes to the middle of range
deviation goes to the opposite side
deviation
and now is breaking out again okay so
let's see what happens
because it's not looking but the SMP at
the moment
obviously we have the fomc meeting in
five days
which is gonna bring a lot of volatility
and then the SMP is gonna have to decide
what direction to take from here if it's
gonna break to the upside or to the
downside to the 4000 Zone okay
so
I would say that these next five days
well comes in the weekend for for
Bitcoin okay so it's five days with a
week and four Bitcoin
be very careful with your trading let's
go back to bitcoin a second
what is bitcoin
Bitcoin
this one
it's gonna be a very difficult time to
trade Bitcoin until we have the fomc
meeting because I think that the most
likely thing is that price starts to
consolidate in this Zone okay
go to the one hour time frame
sorry let me remove all of this so you
can see more clearly
the most normal thing is that Bitcoin
starts to develop the weekend range soon
okay
and you could start seeing something
like this okay over the weekend
this kind of price action you want to
avoid through the weekend
because here when we are about you know
five days from the fomc's when you start
to see price being quite choppy a lot of
traps due to the stop losses get
triggered it's not nice soon to trade to
be honest so you know we've done the
homework for the week it's been a good
week of it all you know we've taken I
would say two three very good trades
so what's the point in risking or
capital in a zone that is not going to
give us high probability trades so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pay attention
to the 150ma and you can already see
that it might have been interrupt that
week sorry this Candlestick and if this
our candle closes above the 1 hour 50ma
I'm gonna cut my short position okay
remember that I took myself position
around here and yes close it almost
break even it's a very small profit okay
Bitcoin hasn't really moved much so
that's kind of how I'm gonna apply it
maybe I get surprised and I start to see
this safely in a big move
or over the weekend but I'm not
expecting so so that's why I have this
very I would say cosus and conservative
plan
okay I never want to raise much of my
money in the next days I want to see how
the fomc plays out that day and see the
imbalances that they might create and
then yes I will trade imbalances the
same as we traded this liquidity pool
so that's my idea
every single trade should have a plan
and an execution
because this video Don't execute your
trades tell me why you are making
analysis of it it doesn't make any sense
so you have to train both fix the
analysis to see that you understand
price action and also the execution
by anyway guys
I don't want to bore you much more this
weekend it is gonna be quite different
videos unless if we start to see some
interesting Bitcoins
because I'm probably not gonna trade
Bitcoin over the weekend okay
so expect some kind of different videos
maybe an altcoin analysis
maybe chain link
where it could be a good Zone to buy if
we get opportunity you know
something different so stay tuned guys
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon